其实也不叫硬核吧
就是说我觉得料很足
但是呢实话实说啊
我给到我要告诉大家一个坏消息
就是说我们在准备这节课的时候
我们第一part要讲mercy learning对吧
机器学习啊
积极的基础
其实呢我们这关于这一这个东西
准备了大概三三十多页
三四页
在最后上课之前
最后几分钟
我把最后那些最难的部分全部给删掉了
因为那个实在是太这个这个太太太怎么说呢
这个对大压力太大了
所以呢我觉得在这一节课里面
我们作为games104课
我们核心讲的是游戏引擎
所以呢我们只会跟大家讲一下
machine learning的最基础的结构和应用
而更多的去跟大家讲的是什么呢
就是说在这个游戏的这个scenario里面
我怎么去用machine learning这个方法
我们举的例子就是alpha star
就是著名的这个就是google的DeepMind
用那个AI去打这个星际争霸的案例
我们从这个案例可以着手推荐大家去讲
所以的话呢真正真正复杂的machine learning的
基础的算法理论
其实那是一个需要专门的课程去讲的
真的其实machinery真的是非常非常深的一个东西
而且很值得大家去系统性的去学习
所以呢很遗憾
就是说在这个课程我实在没有办法展开对吧
而且包括很多概念
我觉得我自己掌握的都不是很好
所以的话呢也不能够慢慢弄斧
所以我这边就给大家讲一些
最基础的一些概念好
那么首先much learning的话
毫无疑问啊
就是现在是当下最火的东西
我们认为AI几乎改变了我们整个时代
那么在我们的生活所有的地方
大家都看到machine learning了
对不对
就基本上是无处不在
你基本上每时每刻他都在为你服务
只是你意识不到而已
好那么其实machine learning呢它是一个大的概念
你从它最基础的概念出发的话呢
它实际上几个大的应用场合
第一个呢就是它会分为
就是比如说surprised learning对吧
Unsuprised learning
还有呢simon surprised learning
还有reinforcement learning
强化学习
前面的是监督学习
非监督无监督学习对吧
半监督学习
最后一个是什么呢
哎强化学习
那这个概念听上去很高端啊
高大上
但实际上概念也很简单
就是说所谓的监督学习本质上是个分类器
什么意思
就是说人类打好了标签或者whatever
什么数据告诉你这个东西
比如说这是给你1万张照片
告告诉AI说这是那里面有猫
那你们没猫
然后我再给你100万张照片的时候
因为有那1万张照片的training
它就能够自动对照片进行分类
说啊这是有猫的
这是没毛的
这个其实在啊很多年以前就是有一个比赛
很有名的AI比赛
他每天打的就是叫照片识别成功率
最早以前没有那个那个神经网
deep deep neural dn的时候
实际上哈那个真的是仁者见仁智者见智的算法
但一旦这个是那个那个那个那个深度神经网络
CNN这些东西出来之后
这个这个比赛现在已经变得有点没有意思了
对吧
但是呢确实就是深圳那个就是说suprise learning的话
它最核心的基础其实就是就是一个分类器
包括他做很多回归的这个预测
就是它的基础
那么对于enterprise learning是什么呢
我觉得是一个classroom
就聚类什么意思呢
就是我记得我记得小时候
我们学过那个一些基础的算法
是我记得好像还有个叫fisher什么算法吧
就是给你一堆散乱点
让你找一条线
把它们分成那个两两趴
我好像有点不太记得了
但是呢其实就是给你很多数据
你对它进行聚类
那么就无深度学习的话呢
它自动可以在数据中找到规律
对它进行聚类
这个东西其实是有用的
比如说我们在很多推荐算法中
我们要对用户进行画像对吧
用户画像有几百个上千个维度
那你就你没有办法
任何人可以告诉你说
诶我怎么去定义什么什么类型的用户
最后呢他只能把这些海量呢
比如上一集的上10亿级的用户
这几百个上千个维度输入到这个AI系统里面
AI自动的用无监督学习
把它分成各种类型的用户画像
然后呢人类看了之后说哦
你好像讲的是这种类型的用户吧
最后我们人类用我们的这个匮乏的语言
给他贴了个标签对吧
所以有的时候你会发现
AI是能帮你发现很多这个世界的规律的
也是用这种无监督的学习
那么这个就是半监督学习呢
这个其实讲起来很高大上啊
但实际上他做的事情也蛮简单的
就是我们人类不用给你那么多案例
是简单的告诉你几个案例诶
接下来你就可以基于这些有限的信息
我对这个世界进行氛围
就相当于你给这个无监督学习
做了一点小小的影子
这件事情有没有用处呢
实际上还是非常有用处的
因为这也是AI现在研究的一个
很重要的一个领域
就是叫小样本学习嘛
就是说我们人类是很聪明的
就是说有的时候一个小朋友你跟他说那是老虎
他只见过两次
但是呢你给他看动物世界的时候
或者看什么东西
他马上跟你说
那是老虎对吧
它就是几个样本
人类就能学会
那是个老虎
但是的话呢如果你交给如果监督学习的话
你可能要上万张照片
确定他说啊
这是老虎
那不是老虎诶
我们的监督学习才有结果
所以其实小样本学习的话呢
也是现在人工智能一个很重要的领域
特别是我们未来如果走向那种叫强人工智能吧
我们其实很需要这个这样的一种能力好
那么最后一个也是最重要的东西叫做强化学习
Reinforcement learning
那么这个强化学习其实非常的重要
就是说在这里面的话
没有一个监督者
也没有人告诉你这件事情是对的还是错的
但是呢他对这个世界呢
它有一个叫rewarding激励的这个函数
就是你做对了
他给你一点甜头吃
做错了给你点那个那个反向的惩罚
那么这个AI算法
它能自己的去不断的优化和迭代
最终形成自己的一个什么呢
哎叫策略
叫policy
大家还记得我讲了policy这个词对吧
那么形成自己的策略
最后能够使自己的结果达到最优
而强化学习这件事情呢其实是非常重要的
那么这里面就是很多时候
我们现在讲这个机器学习
很多时候都认为说
是不是最近几年神经网络的高度发达
所以我们这些概念都出来了
事实上并不是
其实强化学习这个概念
在这个机器人学里面很早就提出来了
真的这个这件事情真的是非常了不起的
就是说我一直这样
就是如果我们对知识掌握得足够多的时候
你会意识到
就是说这个是我们非常感恩
这个星球上产生了很多很优秀的聪明的前辈
他们真的给我们奠定了基础
就是在那个时代
就是大家就在提出各种算法和理论框架
就是怎么样的
让机器形成一个自我不断强化学习的能力
这种能力
我后面再讲到这个心机的这个案例的时候
大家会意识到这玩意儿几乎就是你左脚踩右脚
一开始笨得要死
然后自己左脚踩右脚
最后让自己越来越聪明的这样一个神奇的过程
所以我很我觉得reinforcement learning这个词
选的也是特别的好
那么其实reinforce learning的话呢
它本质上是一个就是try and error search
就是尝试以及给你反馈错误的
这样的一个一个一个一个搜索
但这里面有个很难的一件事情是什么呢
就是说你你对这个系统的学习呀
很多时候他对你的rewarding是delay的
我举个例子
比如说老鼠走迷宫的这个案例对吧
我们在迷宫的终点处放一个那个cheese
放一个奶酪
那对于老鼠来讲
我最后吃到那个奶酪
我肯定很高兴嘛
对不对
我在这个迷宫中间呢
我再放几个陷阱
你掉进陷阱里面
你命都没有了
对不对
好这个时候我怎么去训练这个AI
让他去指挥这个老鼠的行动的策略
这里面一个很难的问题是什么呢
就是说老鼠它在每一步走到迷宫中
任何一个点的时候
我到底是向左走
向右走
向前走的时候
其实他的rewarding并不会发生的
对不对
他如果如果我们设计说
我希望老虎老鼠尽快的走
那你每走一步
我会认为给你一个惩罚叫简易
你掉到悬崖里
我给你直接减个1万
但是的话实际上最重要的
比如说到达终点的奖励是1万的奖励
那个掉进陷阱扣掉1万的这个惩罚
实际上都是非常deferred
他是delay的
那这个时候我的学习系统
怎么样能学习到这样的东西
实际上这也是强化学习一个很难的一个问题好
那么其实整个这个就这这一类的问题的话呢
其实很早以前就数学上给出了一个定义
就是马尔可夫链对吧
马尔可夫决策过程
那么在这个就MDP了
这个东西的话
我相信很多上过大学的同学
好像都理工科
计算机的专业都应该学过这件事情吧
就是说实际上在这个很早以前
我们就把这个概念已经给你抽象清楚了
首先呢我这个世界是什么呢
有一个AI t agent
就是他呢会做出一个角色动作
然后呢会形成一个状态
这个状态的话
在和这个世界这个environment的形成互动
所以environment就是我们这个AIT所生存的
整个世界的总额
比如像老鼠迷宫这个案例里面
老鼠就是那个agent对吧
老鼠脑子里面是有一套什么东西呢
我们叫做policy
叫策略
待会我再讲
就是他我很难按照这个PPT讲
因为你会发现当你讲这个AI的问题时候
他真的都在一起
然后呢这个世界是什么呢
这个environment是什么呢
就是那个迷宫
对不对
这个迷宫里面这个environment会包括那个cheese
也包括那些陷阱
对吧好
那么好
那其实呢在任何一个时候
我们的agent和这个世界会构成一个东西叫什么呢
叫做一个状态对吧
状态就是当前这个A键在感知到的一个世界
和这个整个这个环境
在游戏里面就是这个我们人类设计的环境
比如超级马里亚里面这个state
就是我马里亚输出
现在到底站在哪个坐标点对吧
我的世界上各种比如金币在哪里
我的前面的小怪在哪里
对不对好
我有这样的一个state
接下来呢我有我行动的选择
比如说以超级马里奥二为例的话
那我的action其实非常的简单
只有三个选择
往左走
往右走
往上跳对吧
所以你会发现诶他的整个动作空间很小
只有三个
但是的话呢当我在当前的状态
我做了一个动作之后
诶我就会什么呢
我会形成一个新的state
所以你会发现马尔可夫过程它是个循环
它就不断的循环
所以呢他就会啊形成这样的一个
就是说一个就是他有的时候说一个叫tuber
就是一个一个三元数吧
就是说啊哦这三样书里面还有一条
我待会再讲好
最后一个什么呢
就是奖励
比如说我吃了一个金币
你还给我加一分
对不对
如果我赢了这个游戏
你给我加1万分
但是如果我碰到了这个小怪
我被吃掉了怎么办
那我就要扣1万分
我就游戏是失败了嘛
如果我只是在做一些无效的移动怎么办
你给我说的是零嘛
对不对
我就一来一去
其实你用这个就是说state action和和那个和reward
其实就构成了一个这个世界的一个完整的表达
而所谓的马尔可夫的这个决策过程的话
就是无限的在这循环
就是你现在有个叫啊SSA
还有二的一个状态
这个时候我做出了一个A键呢
做出了一个一个一个一个一个策略
我决定做下一个动作
下个动作之后我的状态就被更新了对吧
然后呢我的rewarding也会变化了
然后呢唉这个时候我又决定我下一个action是什么
所以他就这样来回循环循环循环好嗯
那么其实在这样的话
我们就可以得到一个就是马尔可夫过程的一个
数学表达
这个地方
我其实已经把很多很复杂的数学公式
全部摘掉了
这个我我真的大家一定要那个理解我们的痛苦
因为我们发现就是这节课程
我们不太可能会把这个machine learning的
基础的理论给讲明白
所以我们只会给大家讲一些最基础的数学概念
首先的话呢其实呃在这个过程中的话
其实它最核心的一个数学表达是什么
就是一个叫一个词
一个叫测这个possibility
一个概率函数
就是说当我在当前的策略的S的情况下
我去take一个action
比如说A
那我达到一个新的状态的possibility多少诶
这个很有意思啊
他不是说我在当前策略下
我就是做了动作
A我就一定能到S1撇的那个状态
但这里面其实可能是一个概率
这个是有道理的
因为在很多我们在决策的过程中
就是说我们康是我们的主观上
会有很多我们自己的判断对吧
我认为这个事情我怎么做了
我就可能会赢
但实际上环境是不受你控制的
所以环境一直在变化的话
他有可能会让你的一些动作可能会成功
可能会失败
对不对
比如说我假设让AI做一个我决定射箭的动作
对吧
我决定要打掉前面的小怪
但是大家仔细想想
我如果那个下一个状态是那个小怪
被我打掉的话
如果我是百分之百能把那个小怪打掉吗
或者AI来设计
你觉得AI决定设计他就百分之百能卖你社死呢
其实不会对吧
玩家他会有很多的行为
所以我在设计这个马尔可夫过程的时候
实际上是个概率函数
比如说我精英怪准头很准对吧
我有八成的概率一枪秒了一箭秒了你
但是呢我的我的我的这个其他的小怪的话
我可能经常设的设法不准
我只有1/10的概率能秒到你
所以说这里面的这个possibility of transform的话
transition的话
of state实际上是非常重要的一个一个一个函数
这问题
所以其实其实我们在讲
那个我们内部在讨论这个事能力的时候
我们经常互相被我
我经常就被K说
王鑫你又搞错了
这个地方不是一个不是个函数
不是一个量
它是一个
它是个什么呢
它是个随机变量对吧
它所有的可能性都有
我把我惹急了
我就说嗯好像我用量子力学可以理解一下对吧
就是这个原子对吧
它只是一个状态
它只是它是不函数
他在这个1430之前的话
它的真正的值你是不知道
你只能知道他在这个点出现的概率是多少对吧
所以这个地方是个possibility
一个函数
第二个东西呢也是个非常重要的概念
同学们要去理解的就是policy policy
那这个policy是什么呢
就是我们的AI系统的核心
你可以简单把它理解成
就是说我的
无论你是用neural network还是用有限状态机也好
你还是用一个最土的一个表格也好
它呢它就会形成一个policy的一个黑箱
诶
它的策略黑箱
当你把一个状态输入进去之后
他给你输出什么东西呢
输出我现在该做什么一个动作
诶
这个地方最简单对吧
我一个状态A进去
我就出来我做什么动作
这个地方听上去是不是很好理解
但是这个地方我讲的是错的
实际上呢它输出的是所有可能动作的概率
什么意思
就是说当我一个状态输进去之后
我会说比如说以刚才超级马里亚为例的话
那么他有三个马里奥
他有三种可能的这个动作
对不对
他应该输出的是向左移动
概率可能是比如说0.7向向向右移动
可能是0.1
那向上跳可能是0.2
它当然这个地方规划
所以其实呢我们状态之间的transition
它是一个possibility
是一个随机变量的随机函数
变量的函数的话
那其实这里面policy就是我的这个策略的话
它也是一个随机变量
对这个听上去是不是很深奥
没关系
这些东西呢大家听听就好
因为今天我们不展开这个machine learning的细节
但是同学们一定要知道这个概念
就是说因为其实我们无论是用神经网络
用各种各样的东西
它核心优化的就是这个policy的这个机制
这个函数你可以认为他这个函数
你是用那个神经网络
你还是用这个就是状态机
还是用刚才我们讲的一个
当然我们前面讲的所有的东西
比如说构图也好
我们的HTN也好
那个有限状态机也好
be a tr好
你把它整个封在一起啊
你可以把它理解成他就是一个policy的
这样的一个就是一个policy
它有一个输出状态的输出啊
输出它就会有一个动作的输出
大家想想是不是这样的好
那么最后呢就是我们要去算他的这个total reward
对吧
就是a total reward这个东西呢
实际上有一个很巧妙的东西
就是因为你是一个马尔可夫的一个过程
马尔可夫课程最核心的讲的意思是什么
就是说我们要把这个世界上发生的事情
变成离散的
Step by step
那么而且因为未来的更多的步骤
其实是没有被发生的
对不对
所以我是对未来的世界的一种预测
那么你对未来的reward预测最简单的直接是什么
就是说从我当前的这一步走了这个动作的reward
到我后面所有的reward加在一起
是不是就是我的总reward加在一起
就是我的game对吧
但是的话呢马尔可夫的有一个就很多
在很多AI系统有一个假设是说
因为未来有大量的不确定性
所以呢我认为我走这一个动作之后
我做了这个action之后
我到了下个state的
我获得的奖励是靠谱的
我能把握得住的
再走一步的奖励的话呢
他就有那么一点点不靠谱了
那我乘上个什么呢
诶我乘上一个系数与伽马
我可能设计成比如说0.99对吧
0.999没关系
但是呢当你走了100步之后
你那时候说的是version的话
就是0.99的100次方
你会发现它很小了
它已经不起作用了
所以其实它就是一个就是这个东西是有合理的
其他就平衡一件事情
就是说我们当时在讨论这个东西的时候
我们我们的AI的老同学们说了一个比方
特别有意思
他就说你看啊
你今天这个要好好读书
你将来以后就能够特别特别的成功
这件事情重不重要
当然重要了
我将来能赚一个亿对吧
我就完成了我的人生的小目标
但是你现在会发现
你这个时候如果不去吃饭
你今天晚上那个几天之后你就会饿死
那所以你将来赚一个亿的目标的权重
有那么高吗
没有那么高
所以你现在最重要的事情是什么
赶快找到一个地方把肚子填饱
否则你会饿了对吧
所以呢其实这个这个权重呢
那个函数它就在平衡
就是短期收益和长期收益之间的一个一个目标
所以当你做AI it的时候
如果你希望它更加的就是长期的目标追问的话
那你就把伽马设置的尽量的靠近一
甚至就设成一也没有关系对吧
其实在不同的AI系统中的话
有的时候他真的就设成E了
但是你希望这个就是这个这个AI体呢
更加的responsive
就是说更加的顾眼前
更加的响应速度快
那你会发现你把伽马设的稍微激进一点
比如说设计个0.99990.98对吧
甚至你可以设置成0.95也没有问题
那这个时候你就不可能太太太低了一点啊
那么你这个时候就可以去引导这个行为
所以说其实你会发现
其实马尔可夫决策课程中间的话
它最核心的几个元素就是这个元素
第一个就是说我动作就是我的state transition
它的这个possibility这个分布
实际上就是你可以理解成是一种
概率上的一种graph
第二个呢就是我核心呢我的policy
我反复迭代和优化的就是我的policy
是我的策略方程
那么最后呢
我的策略方程优化的这个指引者是什么呢
实际上是我的就奖励设计
我的奖励设计的话
你可以设计成一种就是更加的平的
也可以设计成随着时间衰减的都可以
所以这是MDP的一个数学的核心表达好
那么其实policy的话呢
在我们的很多的这个就是deep in里面
我们都会写成一个巨大的一个派函数
他们他的核心的输出输出就能看到
我讲的是你给出一个状态的时候
我会告诉你说你做下一个动作的
做那个动作的possibility
比如说以马里奥问题
你看到没有
就是往左走
我们设成0.2了
但我讲的不太好
但是没关系
那往右走是0.1
我这个时候往上跳是0.7
但实际上我觉得这个例子举得
为什么上上上上跳0.7呢
因为这个时候我的状态里面你发现没有
我头顶上有一只金币对吧
我前面什么呢
前面有只小乌龟
如果我的AI没有做错的话
这是我的AI的策略
应该是跳起来吃金币
而且躲过那个小乌龟对吧
那说明这个这个policy这个系统
这个pad做的还是不错的
那么讲到这儿的话呢
其实在这一页之后
大概还有六七页
我们给大家讲什么呢
讲这个叫V函数
Q函数什么意思
就是在每个state上面
我们有个微函数会说
告诉你说这个state到底是不是好的还是坏的
那么这个CD有了之后
我们还有一个叫Q函数
告诉你说在这个世界上你做这个一个动作
它到底收益是好的是坏的
然后基于V和Q函数呢
我们有两种优化方法
一种是基于这种叫做policy gradient的
这个这个这个就是SIRI
就是说哎我是用这个就叫做什么呢
我的这个梯度优化法对吧
如果我这个这个这个策略网络是一个可微的
那我找他的梯度
那我去优化我的整个这个策略
那或者是呢我整个在全局的就是policy
整体的去优化它啊
这个想起来就什么actor actor critical啊
什么很奇怪的一些东西了
那这个地方听上去就是各种
这个不是讲人话的东西了
所以呢其实我们最后在上课之前的话
决定写到这一趴就结束了
就不要再讲了
就是说因为这其实就是machine learning的一个
很核心的基础概念
但是他这些东西他具体怎么做
数学上它是怎么去证明的
实际上那是一个很深的一门课
那门课一讲肯定是讲不完的
就大家如果学过一些那个B站上一些
非常好的一些
就是那个就讲那个深度学习的一些方法的话
我觉得你们会讲的非常的好
但是呢做AI做游戏AI的话
我们知道这些基础的概念
接下来更重要的事情是
怎么把这些东西用在我们的游戏里面去
好那这些
所以接下来就讲一个非常有趣的东西
就是哎我们怎么利用这个machine的这个行业的发展
来benefit我们游戏游戏AI
这里面注意啊
我讲的是游戏里的AI
不是用deep learning的方法去做
比如说游戏的内容生成
比如现在一个很火的方向叫PCC
就是基于这个AI的
比如说基于算法的这个内容生成对吧
其实还有很多的
比如说我生成动作啊
生成这种让人物的行为更加自然
这些都是很多很优秀的方向
但今天的话呢我们focus会非常specific的讲
就说我怎么让游戏里面的这个AI变得更聪明
那为什么这里面我们要在游戏里面考虑
使用像much learning这样的东西呢
其实有一点就是说他会发现
我们过去所有的前面讲的AI算法比
无论是HTN的还是GP的话
它实际上都是人类的设计师设计出来的对吧
人类设计师一切对于比如说你的动作能做什么
你有哪些动作
包括你该以什么一种关系串在一起
已经一切了然于心了
所以这就意味着什么呢
这就意味着就是说这个AI的行为
应该也不会超过我们人类的预期
而且他很可能我们的想象力
就直接决定了这个AI的上限
但是呢那么是learning的方法是什么呢
特别是强化学习
它是可以AI自己去进化
不断的去创造各种可能性
所以它实际上就把游戏的这个行为
变得更加的无限可能
那这件事情为什么对游戏特别重要呢
因为想象一下
我们我们认为未来的游戏的发展
它是给人类构建一个更加的就是believable的
一个像真实世界这样的一个无限可能的世界
那我们想象一下
为什么我们人类旅游
为什么我们喜欢结交新的朋友
就是因为当你面对这些新的世界
新的朋友的时候
他会给你带来完全不一样的体验和感受对吧
让我们有新鲜感
所以说其实一个好的游戏
这是我至少我个人的believe啊
就是我认为未来的游戏
它一定是当我每一次登录游戏的时候
他要给我带来一些新东西
我不想去
每次去主城主持人的NPC都跟我说同样的话
对不对
很讨厌对吧
那么但是大家回想一下10年前的游戏
是不是NPC永远的repeat the same words again again
但是大家想象一下
荒野大镖客这样的大表哥的游戏
一进去之后发现诶
这NPC的行为好像看上去好像很human like的
对不对
但是呢我记得好像有一个B站上的一个up主
他去跟了那个大表哥里的NPC更了好像是一天吧
他后来发现说诶
已经发现这里面有些repeat了对吧
但没关系
我不知道它里面是不是用了这种
我是能力的方法
但是我认为这已经push for了
但确实在我们这个领域里面的话
我们确实在思考
就是用这种深度学习的方法
包括一些那个机器的这些人工智能的东西
让这里面的游戏AI真的会思考
会探索无限的可能性
这也是我们一直一个梦想好
那么我们怎么样在一个游戏里面去构建一个
基于machine learning的这样一个firm work呢
这里面的话呢其实没有大家想象的那么fancy
其实在游戏里面你想构建这个它的
比如说人工智能的东西的话
其实最重要的一件事情是构建这个游戏的这个
Observation
就是说你把游戏里所有的状态
能够定量化的表达出来
就以你作为一个游戏而言的话
就是说你要把这个游戏里面所有的状态
用state表达出来
这样你这时候才能变成一个电脑可以感知的
这样的一个世界
那么你有了这样的一个世界之后
你反复优化的是什么呢
是你的policy对吧
这里面policy又来了
就是说当我的世界在这个状态的时候
我这个时候我的AI应该做什么样的一个动作
然后呢这个世界会发生改变
而且对我会更好
所以它其实是这样一个大的循环
那这里面我就举一个例子
哎这里面就讲一个更具的
因为这个问题讲的非常的抽象
其实如果我们用deep reinforce learning
就dire是stands for deep reinforce learning
深度强化学习这样的一个框架去构建一个
比如像星际争霸的这样的一个游戏的话
我该怎么做
这里面的话呢
你会发现你有这么很重要的几步
第一步就是对这个世界状态的描述
我们叫做state对吧
就是你大家想象一下我们打星际的时候
你看到的是什么
是一个一个的像素
对不对
那我们人会怎么样
我们的大脑会把这些像素抽象成各种语义
对不对
这是我的基地
只是敌人的冰
那是敌人飞在天空上的航母对吧
这是我的机枪兵
这是我的那个那个那个医疗兵
然后小地图上红的点蓝的点
对不对
资源点看得一清二楚
那等等
还有我的血量各种状态
所以这些state实际上是需要有一个量化的方法
表达给我们的AI系统
第二个是什么呢
哎我的我有了这个世界的表达之后
我要定义说电脑AI到底指挥我的这个这个游戏
做什么
你要定义你的action
其实action这件事情并不简单
因为大家想象一下
我如果我的电脑控制的输出
叫鼠标的点击拖动是吧
这个就很奇怪了
对不对
其实比如说如果我让小兵让电脑打星际的话
实际上呃
他很可能是直接给那个小兵发一个移动指令
当然这里面有作弊的嫌疑啊
所以实际上在真实的这个AI与人类对抗的时候
他甚至会模拟人类的手速
都是都需要去模拟的
但anyway
就是说其实action的话也是需要被定义好的好
第三个呢其实也很有意思
就是说大家想象一下啊
我去打一场像星际这么复杂的游戏
那我一场游戏要打大概将近一个小时吧
长一点
短一点
30分钟
20分钟
那在这么漫长的时间里面的话
我每隔比如说一秒钟思考三次
我去做他的角色的话
那我其实会产生几千步上万部
但是我怎么去知道这个东西胜负
是有道理的对吧
我要设计它的rewarding激励
最简单的revolting很简单
就是剩剩了给一分对吧
输了给零分
那个啊输了给一分
假如评论给零分对吧
有的游戏是没有平局的
但是这个rewarding设计的就很粗暴
但是这个rewarding能不能work work
但是你如果希望这个AI更加聪明
更加有效的话
实际上你要设置它很多的动作的奖励
后面我们会讲到那么好
第三第四件事情是什么呢
就是说根据你要做的这个
游戏的本身的结构和逻辑
你要构建你的这个neural network的这个拓扑结构
和它的网络选型
这件事情其实是非常考验这个团队的基本功的
那么这件事情对于每一个不同的游戏
根据它的游戏的核心机制
你的设计方法确实不一样
最后呢就是哎你有了这个
你把世界抽象成了这个状态了
对不对
你定义了所有AI可以指挥小兵做这个
指挥这个bot做的状态
然后呢你也设计了非常合理的几样零函数
你也设计了一个非常贴切的这个
这个网络拓扑结构好
你是不是都work了
哎没有那么简单
你还要设置一个训练的策略
因为假设你不认真的设计训练策略的话
你的这个I其实也很笨
待会我们讲到那个阿尔法star的时候
大家会发现这里面很微妙
好
这其实他开发现就是说
虽然听上去大家觉得这个人工智能
那个那个深度学习好像很强大
但是你把这样一个强大的工具用在游戏的一个
具体的scenario的时候
你会发现这个事很复杂
这里面我再多说一句
就是说其实大家刚才我们第一个案例
讲蒙特卡的research mc t的时候
我们讲的是阿尔法go的例子
就是下围棋的例子
我们讲过围棋多复杂对吧
pony爸爸说他比宇宙的原子还要多
但是我跟大家讲一件事情
就是说其实对于围棋这样的一个博弈来讲的话
计算机用这个方法
计算机用蒙特卡洛吹测试方法
再加上一点那个深度学习的东西
现在已经完胜人类了
那为什么呢
因为对于项棋类运动啊
他的信息第一个是对称的
就是所有人看到的奇迹是一样的对吧
而我们真正打游戏的时候
什么我们有个叫战争迷雾
大家想想看
所以它是一个叫信息不对称的这样的一个博弈
第二件事情的话呢
围棋的规则你每走一步
它的步骤是非常明确的
所以接下来我讲了
如果我有无限的算力
和无限的这个存储空间的话
理论上是有必胜策略的
好在这样的一种博弈里面的话呢
目前啊好像是人工智能已经干过了人类了对吧
大家都知道围棋最近发生的事情对吧
但是在像游戏
比如像星际争霸这样的游戏里面
到目前为止
全世界还没有AI能够完善人类的player怎么样
我们人类的最后的尊严还最终保住了
对对于这种超复杂系统的博弈来讲
我们人类的大脑
毕竟我们有1000亿个神经元嘛对吧
我们还是勉强苟延
残喘了我们人类的荣光
所以其实我这句我讲这句话的意思是什么呢
我想告诉大家
就是说其实游戏的这个scenario里面
如果构建一个这样的一个人工智能的话
实际上难度还蛮大的
而且呢你很你真的想做的很好
其实非常的挑战好
接下来就讲一下这里面的很多的细节好
我们这里面的话
我们就举个例子
我们就不叫举个例子
其实这也是我们发现的最好的例子
就是alpha star
阿尔法star就是我们的DeepMind
在几年前用这个就是它的这个神经网络
这个技术构建的
是跟人类打星际的这样一个例子
那么他首先第一步是什么呢
我要对游戏的整个状态进行表达
那么第一个
那么整个一个星际界面打开了
你会发现没有
里面是有很多的哎
很多的图
很多的map小地图也好
我一眼看见的东西也好对吧
然后呢我还有很多游戏的统计数据对吧
我还有很多单位在地图上跑
怎么样呢
我还有什么呢
还有我自己的各种数据都在里面
所以这些东西的话呢
是实际上就是我对世界的state
那state的具体怎么去表达呢
这样的东西其实AI是不知道的
那我们就要对各种state进行定量的表达
第一种是什么呢
就是各种各样的map
比如说我的整个地形的高程图对吧
什么地方是高地
什么地方是平地
如果打过星际的小伙伴
就知道高地的意义是很不一样的
比如说我的飞行单位可以去攻击任何高地上
高地上的目标
但是的话呢
我的地面单位如果没有条通很多高地
我上不了
比如说我们以前那个星际地图
可以自己编辑的时候
有人会做个非常变态的图像
这个图像有无数的高地
都是都是孤岛对吧
就地面单位永远上不去
所以我必须要用航母啊
或者是那个就是那个飞行飞龙啊
去攻击那些地方
第二个的话是什么呢
我的战争迷雾
它本身是不是也是一张图对吧
还有什么呢
诶我这个比如说地面地表的各种状态的变化
比如说在那个就心机里面有个叫重组重塑
它要在那个地方去渐进任务
它首先什么要把那个地方先感染了对吧
他那个地方需要被感染掉
那么还有什么呢
就是我什么地方发生了警报
还有呢我什么地方可以寻路的
这个这个图还有什么呢
就是说哎其实很多的在AI这种设计中
我的叫inforce map
就是比如说威胁图像这些东西在里面也会协同
在上一节课的时候
我们讲了game play的时候
也讲到了这个东西
所以其实啊我对一个游戏的态势的表达
可以用很多层的这样的一个map去表达
这些东西呢
我们人类看起来是很抽象的
你看不明白的
但是你交给计算机
不妨碍计算机
它能够去读懂这些信息
所以你可以把整个战场博弈的态势
转化成一层层的map传给他
那么第二点是第二种数据是什么呢
就是各种各样的unit的information对吧
你的哎你面前unit的type是哪些
对不对
是什么类型的
比如说是机枪兵
护士兵还是这个什么坦克对吧
然后呢这些人到底是敌方友方还是盟友对吧
你还有这些人血量怎么样了
对不对
还有他们的现在的位置在哪里
这个我就不一一展开了
但实际上是让这些信息是什么呢
它不是一个map信息
它是一个离散信息
一串一串串的数据过来好
你有了这样的一些信息之后
我们接下来干什么一件事情呢
我们要定义说我到底能做什么一件事情
比如说以星际这样的游戏为例的话
我们就要定义说哦
你是moon attack build对吧
三个最核心的问题
但是呢这问题听上去很简单
你能做什么
但是你要知道who对吧
是谁去做这件事情对吧
因为心机里面你同时给个指令的时候
有的时候给的不是一个单位啊
你给的实际上是一群人对吧
第二个就是你要攻击的对象也可能是个人
你到底攻击谁呢
你是攻击一个建筑物
还是攻击对方的一个
比如说飞龙
你还是打掉对方的一个什么
这个就是一个一个一个坦克对吧
你自己决定那么打去
比如说你如果是木的话
你到底要去哪个点
因为有的时候我我去的点是只是个坐标嘛对吧
所以说其实包括你后面的
比如说如果我们有一定的planning的话
我可能输出的动作不是只有一步
我可能好几步
比如说我要求你先移到那个点
接下来你在那个地方给我建一个基地
新一个分基地建起来
所以说其实action的定义对于游戏去做这个AI来说
非常的重要
你要定义的非常非常specific
非常非常的清楚好
接下来的话呢我们要设置奖励
那么这里面的话还是有很神奇的事情的
比如说像我们去读那个阿尔法star的文章的时候
我们就很惊奇的发现
就是说他说我的奖励设计的非常的直接
就是我只设置win and lost
就是win我给你加一一分
书就减一分
但其实呢它这里面还做了一个小小的这个
这个优化
他说呢就是说他会把游戏中很多的一些状态
比如说这些啊
一些比如distant agent
agent之间的这个这个就是就是电脑算出来的
这个就是大家记得policy
对不对
我用我的我的电脑
给出了我下一步操作的这个动作
和人类
如果在这种情况下
他做的动作我做过比较
如果他两个不一样的话
我对他有一个反向的惩罚
如果一样
我做过这样的惩罚
我我做一些的一堆的CRITERI去引导我的做法
就这个地方我们就看傻了
我们就说哎呀大哥
你这个地方对吧
胜负只按正一去给
那你这东西到底给多少呢
你是给这个100还是给1万
如果你给100和1万的话
那显然胜负这件事就没有意义了
对不对
那如果给的太小
它也不起动了
为此的话我们还专门请教了国内的一些大牛
他们告诉我说啊
因为我们自己没有实践过阿尔法star这边paper嘛
就是我们就去拜托他们
他们跟我说
他说哎
其实他们的大致的给了这个数值加了权重
让这些所有的这一项的一些叫做relevant
这样的一个sudo relevant
Sual reward
叫伪基地的话呢
它的总加在一起的范围
大概值域范围大概在正一之间
就是跟那个VR的loss基本匹配
但是呢就不会超过它
但这里面的权重怎么设置
怎么算
就是他们自己的黑科技了
但是呢这个是阿尔法斯的方法
但我个人觉得其实有很多其他方法
这里面举举另外一个例子
这个例子就是那个OpenAI five
这个open范围也是很有名的一个AI系统
就大家如果喜欢打DOTA的人
肯定都听说过
就是这个是OpenAI做的一个就是啊就是打DOTA的AI
那么打的应该是DOTA2
那么这里面很有意思的事情
他为什么叫five呢
因为大家想想DOTA上上场都是五个英雄对吧
那么他呢就设计的非常符合我们玩家的理解
比如说对吧
你胜负当然会给你分数了
但是哎你偷了个塔对吧
你干掉了一个英雄
比如说你被人家这个
你你你你被人家砸中了一个一个技能
你受到了伤害对吧等等
所有的事情他都给你一个小小的激励
这些小小的机理在一起
就形成了一个非常高频的一个rewarding系统
这样的话而且他还有一个很巧妙的地方
就是说因为你设置了这么多的小奖励
实际上你比如说把击杀英雄这件事情
他的reward给的足够高的话
你实际上就能够定义他的AI的行为
就是非常的aggressive
他会更加的想去砍人对吧
如果呢你把它胜负看的这个特别重的话
这个AI就会怎么样呢
他会非常的这个这个非常的保守
非常的安全
他就优先把这设计做
就这他就优先以胜负大局为重对吧
很有格局
那所以的话呢
其实我就可以通过这些变量的调整
就这些rewarding调整
让我的AI有各种各样行为的变化
那么其实跟新机一样
就是到现在为止的话
open a f好像还是打不过人类的top tier的玩家
哎这个我们人类最后的荣誉还是保持住了啊
但这句话我觉得这个flag还是不能立得太早
说不定再过几年AI的发展
真的把我们又摁在地上摩擦了我
我突然觉得有种莫名的荣誉感
你看啊
这个围棋这么古老的一个运动被AI碾压了
但是我们这么新兴的一个运动
电竞
到目前为止还是人类的圣光
保持保持在我们的这个没有没有熄灭对吧
那这个灯塔的话
我们希望我们人类选手保持的越久越好
所以呢这里面单单从回到我们这个这个课程
算法里面讲的话
就是说其实当我们用这个啊
就是deep deep reinforce learning的方法去做游戏的AI的时候
其实rewarding的设计
包括它是高频和低频呢非常的重要
就它直接会影响到你最后这个系统产出
那么你有了这样一个东西的时候
诶
我们就开始要构建我们的这个训练的这个
这个神经网络系统了
大家看到这张图是不是有一点
这个非常的这个密集恐惧症啊
唉不好意思啊
这真的就是这个阿尔法star的
它这个体系架构图
这几乎就是从原文上扣上来了
然后我们唯一做了一个工作干嘛呢
我们画了两个框
所以告诉大家
就是说它下面是一堆的各种各样的输入对吧
其实我们讲了stay的输出
比如说你各种各样的图对吧
然后还有各种各样的游戏的数据
比如说有些数据是游戏的统计数据
有些数据是这个玩家的unit的数据
它扔到了不同的这个架构的这个神经网络里面
有的是用这个就是RESNET对吧
处理各种各样的图
有的呢是用这个就是说啊transformer对吧
处理连续的数据
有的呢就是用那个MRP对吧
就这最简单的神经网络处理它
然后最后扔到了一个LT那个TM对吧
那这个听上去很高端了
待会我们会解释整个这一段全部做完之后
干了一件什么事儿呢
他计算机就是这个这个AI
就做了一大堆很奇怪的运算
最后他encode了
形成了他自己这样的一个角色
但这个角色呢人类是读不懂的对吧
他输出了一串的数字
水鬼没有人知道他在讲什么诶
它上面也做了一层网络
这种网络相对就比较简单了
他干了一件什么事情呢
它叫叫decoder
Decoder
就是呢把这一这一堆大脑算完的结果
把它翻译成我们人类能理解的
他的整个行动
这里面就会说诶我有些有些decoder
有些行动就是说我到底要不要空兵
有些行动是我到底要移动对吧
各种东西它就控制好了
所以其实它的整个你去理解它的结构啊
已经分成两层就好了
第一层就是神秘的角色
课程产生了一个谁也读不懂的一些数字
就像一个对大家如果看那个玄玄疑小说的时候
有一个极其聪明的
比如说这个智囊
他分析了整个这个这个天下局面
然后呢给那个就是这个这个这个主公
在墙上写上了一行字
然后一般人看到强子完全看不懂他在说什么
但是呢主公再找一群模式
把那几个字逐字逐字的去解读
去理解
然后最后形成了韬略说啊
这个什么张将军
你带5000人去杀到什么地方去
李将军
你赶快固守我的这个陈强诶
这个decoder就干了
这个事
然后呢最后我这个AI就可以行动起来了
怎么样
听上去是不是呃一下子觉得没有那么高大上了
确实是你如果这么去理解的话
好像也没有那么难对吧
那其实最有意思的就是这个encoder
就是他怎么去决策的这事呢
说实话
就是这也是我一直以来对这个深度学习的一个
怎么说呢
也是我个人不成熟的一个理解
就是因为我有很多朋友
就是应该是全球顶级的这样的一个
人工智能专家
这个地方小小的凡尔赛一下
是他们很优秀
不是我很优秀啊
这个说实话
我每次对他们的敬仰之心都滔滔江水
然后当我每次呢因为有酸葡萄心理嘛对吧
我又我又做的不够好
所以我就开始酸他们了
我就说我说你们做的事情
就是一个那个炼丹的过程对吧
你们设计个丹炉
然后呢把各种材料往里面加面
多加水
水多加面对吧
然后的话呢就是然后呢各种什么朱砂呀
什么这个什么铜铜铜须啊
什么都往里加一通火
烧完之后最后练出一个东西
哎这东西就好了就work了
那这个当为什么练出来的原理是什么呢
你也不知道
大概猜猜可能是这个原因
但其实你也不能给出一个非常scientific的一个
数学证明对吧
那其实今天就是我们深度学习
有个很重要的一个研究方向
就是说为什么这个深度神经网络它就是work的
虽然我能够用一些简单的概念解释它为什么work
但是其实在数学上
我去演绎他的work这些事倒还是挺难的一件事
但是确实有很多很优秀的科工作者在做这个事
所以的话呢其实我们去理解这些大佬们构建的
这个就是这个各种各样的训练的模型啊
其实你就把它想象成这玩意儿就work了
而且他能处理什么样人类的问题
然后呢我们就像拼搭积木一样的把它搭起来
只能解决好我们的问题就可以了对吧
所以很多东西你是不能深究的
至少深究已经超过了我们的智力范围
所以如果按照这种不求甚解的思思路的话呢
诶我们好像就能够把这个这一张神奇的图
就给他解释清楚了
那比如说大家看到其实我们的输入啊
它其实有三类
第一类是什么呢
就是我们讲过的诶这个游戏的基础状态
比如说我的资源量对吧
我各种各样的气呀
我的这个这个各种人口啊
各种资源量在这边
对不对
这就是一个很确定性的
就是定场的一个数据
对不对
他一个游戏中你就那么些数据
第二种是什么呢
各种各样的map对吧
我对游戏态势的感知不就是小地图对吧
我的各种各样的influence map对吧
这种map过来诶
我要对这种图像数据进行处理
对不对
那第三种是什么呢
唉我现在目力所及看到了多少的敌方单位
敌方单位的坐标是什么
我方单位的种类坐标位置
但是这里面有个挑战是什么呢
它的长度是变长的
而且一直在变呢
对不对
你开发现没有
就是说你很难说我现在只看着前1000个
但是如果你真的设计个maximum
然后的话你只用maximum的这个东西
就是所有的没有的
就是成林可不可以可以的
但是呢这个他的这个这个行为表达就很诡异
那这个你的实践网络其他的要求就很高
那么对于这种三种不同类型的数据啊
其实我们的这个这个这个deep learning的先贤们
已经给出了非常好的AI的训练的方法
他怎么说呢
比如说对于你定场的这些数据
我用什么呢
我用MLP
MLP全称叫multi layer perception
它其实就是最简单的多层神经网络对吧
然后呢你你给他一个输出
他就给你一个输出对吧
这样的话你就反复的去反向训练它
它就可以去给出一个你想要的一个结果
所以对于所有的这种固定的环境资源类的数据
我就这样放下来
那么第二类的是什么呢
唉就是各种各样的图
那这个图就很好办了
就用CNCN是什么呢
就convolutional neural network
就是卷积神经网络
那么这里面最大名鼎鼎的叫什么叫RESNET
RESNET的话呢
其实是那个就是孙健博士这道题了
这个很不幸啊
孙健博士最近刚刚去世
其实他生前是我的一个好朋友
就当时我真的是我很敬重他
然后就是他提出了什么
哎我在就是因为因为以前CN还是一层层的嘛
他recenter提出来说
我把前面的那一层的数据我一直往后跳
直接给他们
这样的话
当我就是看那个那个就是我的CN到后面的时候
很多高频的细节的数据都丢掉了
但是因为我有这样的一个跳的话
我很多细节能够传到前面去
那这个像这种CN的东西
它有很大的好处是什么呢
它可以把一个图像数据直接囫囵吞枣
包括我们现在几乎所有的图像识别
都是基于CN的
那比如说我们假设作为一个RTS游戏
模拟人类去看这个世界的感觉的话
其实你应该输出的是什么呢
是人类视角的这个深度图
然后用CNN去识别出来
那边有小怪
那边有敌人
这才是一个公平能力
如果那个人直接点标出来的话
那其实是不公平的
因为我们人类的时候在远处
比如说对方穿了个迷彩服
你就很难发现了
对不对对吧
它或者它只有一个像素
但是如果你假设不用这种
就是啊一米几base的方法的话
你其实很多是在作弊
你说啊1000米之外有一个小怪
它只是距离很远
那你说到底你算你知道还算你不知道呢
对不对
但是呢其实对于这个就是
比如说解决星际的这种图的
星际是一个很典型的RTS游戏嘛
它这个策略游戏
其实在这些各种各样的小地图也好
包括war fog
它本身也是个图对吧
就是战争迷雾也是个图
包括就地球地图上的高低分布
还有地图上的这个我是否探索过的区域
我刚刚探索的区域
这些全部都可以用图来表达
那事实上就是你这些图就可以扔进我们的一个
CNN网络进行处理
产生我想训练的结果
那么接下来第三种呢
就是大量的时间上的不定长的这个数据
那这里面的话就进入了一个著名的transformer
transformer本身是蛮复杂的
就是但他基础思想实际上是在LP里出现的
就是说大家想象一下
我出了一个文本对吧
没头没尾
无穷无尽
第二个呢你很难把它归咎化成一个
比如说一个一个一个一个啊
一个表格或者是一个2D的东西
所以呢transformer的好处
就是说它一直能叠在一起
然后你把数据一直一直一直往里面灌
但是它能够处理这种continues的
没完没了的这样一个变量
那么在这个那个就是那个那个那个
alpha star里面的话
我们对这个世界上的这种
比如说unit这些不正常的东西的话
我们用transformer送进去好
那这三个东西揉到一起之后
他都是离散的
没有处理
对不对
你只是各自好像扔到神经网络
做了一堆其实没有意义的计算
哎接下来怎么让它变得有意义呢
哎我上面再加一层东西
就是LSTM
那这个东西就非常了不起了
就是这个是最早大家提出来
就是说我怎么样让这个神经网络
像人类一样思考
人类对一个信息的处理啊
它不是单纯的说你给我一个东西
我就处理完就出去了
不会的
我们人类还有个东西什么的
我们有个叫反馈和记忆
就是说我上次做了一个决策
这个决策假设是好的或者坏的
其实我会把这个决策记下来
记下来之后呢
我就会影响到我下一次角色
比如说一个东西反复出现
那我认为这个东西可能是高频的
我可能会有些其他的处理模式
对不对
第二就是说我的记忆不会一直持续
我的记忆可能会需要一段时间
我就是假设有不断的新的数据过来之后
那么我可能有些记忆会忘记
所以ASTM的讲起来比较复杂
但是你仔细看那个通路
这里面很有意思
就是说你的信号S进去之后
它会产生一个结果
就H上一次那个H结果那个H那个结果呢
他又反向的回来去修改你的那个你的记忆
那记忆在哪里呢
就是你的cc是什么呢
就是你的脑细胞
所以我们的大脑实际上比大家想象的复杂
就是说它不仅具有计算功能
它还有一个记忆功能
而且我们的记忆我一直认为是一个flash memory
就是闪存对吧
万一断电了
我的记忆就会失意
你看很多那个时脑创伤的病人
如果缺氧之后
他就会有很多东西失忆了
说明什么呢
这个像上次一样断了个电
那你的信息就丢掉了
我们什么时候把我们大脑换成磁盘
可能就很牛逼了
但这个没关系
这不是我要研究的范围
所以其实那个LSTM的话呢
它就像一个这个综合的大脑
它会把这三个不同的
比如说从你的这个就是那个mp
你的那个就是说CN和这个transformer
处理完的数据
最后在我这汇总
但我这个时候建的就会比较复杂
它会具有一定的记忆功能
让我的这个AI能跑起来
那为什么记忆功能很重要
我给大家举个简单的例子
就是说比如说我们在在星际里面打策略的时候
对吧
我前面看见了一个敌人
过一会WOLFA把它盖住了对吧
包括我前面我对方可能变化了一些策略
比如说刚才打五台
现在又跑了
那在当前的状态里面
实际上你并不一定知道他刚才打你的这件事情
但实际上你有了一些记忆功能之后
你就知道说我这些人可能刚才被打过
你想很多是不是很像我们人类思考的过程
所以你用这样的一个东西的话
其实就构建了一个完整的
他这样一个决策的链路
那么decode我们就不展开了吧
就是说实际上的话呢
我们在用deep learning的方法去构建
我们的一个游戏AI系统的时候
其实最重要的就是你选择不同的
neural network的架构
而且呢这些neural network在一起
又本身就构成了一个architecture在一起工作
比如说就再重复一遍
就是比如说对于定常数据的话
用MRP基本上就够了对吧
对于不定长的数据的话呢
我们会用LSTM或者是transformer来处理
那么对于图像相关的数据
我们用这个RESNET
但其实呢这里面还有一些更复杂的数据输出
比如说像recast的数据
大家会觉得为什么我们作为一个游戏
i show recast呢
我给大家讲一下
比如说最前沿的一些游戏AI的研究
比如说我要模拟一个AIT向人类行为的话
我可能像人一样
我发出一系列的射线
我会获取对这个世界的采样
然后我再去决定我的AI的行为
因为这样的话这个AIT它就会很真实
他会就是说他有些人看不见
而且他看不见背后的东西对吧
那这个游戏我就不点名什么游戏了吧
就是做的非常好的一个游戏
那么其实的话呢
这个也是会作为我们AAI的输入
那么像整个mesh也可以作为输
所以这里面的话我就选了个open a f的这个例子
就是说他这个网站做的非常有意思
就是你可以看到在AI的实验里面选中每个单位
你可以看到他所有的这个参数
所以我一直蛮喜欢open a fi
他的做事的方法就是非常的可爱
非常的符合
就是由gamer的这种认知好
那么其实呢
其实这个时候我们就训练我们的AI了对吧
就比如刚才我们加了一个这么复杂的
这个这个这个这个神经网络的架构
不好意思放回去啊
那么好
那我要开始训练它了
那训练它呢
其实大家想想看最理想的方法是什么
不就是大家一直很敬仰的像阿尔法zero对吧
阿尔法go背谱子的不值钱
没有本事
alpha zero只告诉你基础规则
你就可以去打了
这件事情听上去是非常的高大上
但是呢对于游戏这么复杂的一个情况的话
如果你真的像这个阿尔法zero方法
就是你不去不给他任何的先验知识
直接去训练它那个神经网络
那又在这么漫长的reverting的这个链条下
那这个网络能收敛
能给出一个meaningful result
这个时间应该是极其漫长的
时间漫长
你说没关系
我可以等
但是这里面还有一个东西是什么呢
诶是钱money
就是待会我会提到
就是说其实做这个就是基于深度学习的
这样的一个人工智能
其实成本是非常高的
那所以的话呢一个reasonable的解法是什么
就是诶我们先把大量的人类的行为把它放进去
就是用监督学习的方法
首先衬出一个相对OK的这样的一个神经网络
哎这里面就很有意思了
那也就意味着什么呢
就是我先让AI去模仿人类
就是说我把一个state的输进去之后
你如果AI就是因为我们有大量的游戏
有大量的历史数据
对不对
好把这四类数据后
如果你的AI不不去
按照我们人类的一样的去操作
我就打你一下
说你错了
你要学我对吧
那这个时候就像小孩子一样学东西
他有样学样啊
那我想问大家一个问题
就是说你这时候要注意两个东西是什么呢
就比如说你更应该选择什么样的数据去测试呢
唉很多人就这时候想到了
就是说我要什么呢
在人类的玩家的这个数据中
我要挑选那些积分比较高
排名比较靠前的人类玩家作为输出
对不对
这个事情这样做是对的
为什么呢
因为就是说叫这个这个叫shooting the the the mars
黑田的墓
就是说你如果想让这个AI聪明一点
你真的要去找人类最低的这些玩家的行为
去训练它
但一般来讲你训练出的AI的话
不会比这个原作者更聪明
一般都会比他笨那么一点点
但是这不妨碍我们这个AI已经有
就是相当于是能beat一个业余玩家的水平了
那么这里面的话就有一个有一个取舍
就是说如果你选择最top tier的玩家的话
这个数据肯定是最好的
对不对
但是你的数据集比较少
那所以有的时候
我们会选择一个相对平衡的一个点
就是比较优秀的玩家数据输出来就可以了
那这里面再讲一个有意思的概念
就是说
其实像那个那个那个阿尔法star的训练的时候
他用了一个叫kr divergence
就是这是个数学
这个这个数学解释起来就比较比较
比较比较高端了
叫什么呢
叫叫就叫数值差伤吧
就他是用上entropy双商的概念
他就讲两个分布之间诶
他其实会形它两个差会形成一个伤
我要让这个商尽可能的少商为零的时候
就这两个分布基本一致
但是如果伤比较高
说明我们两个的这个决策就差异度比较大
但我就认为这是个不好的网络还是优化的
所以其实在像阿尔法star这样的东西的时候
他一开始是用了大量的人类玩家的行为
去训练出它的基础的这个
网络的这个这个结构啊
接下来的话呢诶我们要进行这个监督学习啊
那个真那个那个就是那个就是那个增强学习
reinforcement learning对吧
那么强化学习让AI开始进行自己互补
这里面其实他用了很多很高端的一些
就是reinforce learning的一些方法
这里面我就不展开了
但是这里面讲一个很有意思的东西
就是说我怎么样子
让这个强化学习能够越学越强
其实呢你有一套强化学习算法
你可以反复的优化你的policy
对不对
但是这种优化它本身还是有上限的
所以呢alpha star它有一个非常了不起的一个方法
这个方法我觉得就是如果我们去做这个嗯
那个就是machine learning的方法做游戏的话
一定可以很很有参考意义
就是他研发了一套叫就是双手互搏的策略
他首先定义了就是它一个叫主a agent的
假设
我缩写为A那么他每天呢是他还跟自己打架的
你就知道了
他这他要双手互搏
他每次都要想办法自己把自己打赢对吧
因为没有人类跟他打嘛
他只能自己打
一天要打个几10万局
上上百万局都没有问题
那么好
那么他这里面不是永远只跟自己打
因为他一旦只跟自己打的话呢
它的这个AI就到一定程度
它就会诶卡在一个点上了
就是其实做deep learning的人都知道
就是你最怕的就是你的这个AI
优化到一个局部最优解
而不是一个全局最优解
他就设计了这样一个策略
就是说首先呢我跟自己打35%对吧
那我剩下的呢我要跟另外一种卷的
我们就是跟所有过去的其他的agent的
比如说啊这里面我们定义了两种选择
一种叫league这个exploiter对吧
还有一个呢叫main exploiter
这个待会我会解释就是是另外的两个agent的
两狼人类agent的
我跟我跟他所有的过去去打
然后呢我还跟我所有过去的自己的A技能去打
打15%
这你们就觉得很奇怪了
就说哪有那么多的AI简易打的
但实际上并不是的
就是AI你就训练出一个版本
假设你只有一个版本
你确定一次它形成第一个版本对吧
那我再确定一段时间
我就生成第二个版本
那我过去可能会生成100个历史的
就是阿尔法star的版本
原则上来讲的话
越早期的阿尔法star版本是不是越笨
对不对
好
我就往下走
我现在是训练我的101了
那这个时候呢
那如果我跟只跟我101水
跟101打
他很容易被自己啊形成一个最优解
所以呢他怎么办呢
所以你先跟自己打35%
你应该知道就是知识它它自进化对吧
就是双手互搏
自己跟自己下棋
但是呢他还和过去的100个过去
自己100个历史也去打
这是最后一版15%
但是呢因为这100个自己呢
也是他一路眼睛过来了
其实也并不能代表这个最高实力
他还要逼着自己又开了另外两个分支
一个分支呢叫做这个legal exploit
什么意思呢
就是说他这一个这一组的agent
他专门就是跟自己和周边的最man的东西去对抗
他
说白了他他就要去找
就是那个啊就是所有的这个其他几个agent的弱点
而且他是跟他们的历史去打的
是专门training的一个一个一个叫做legal
那个ELOITER
另外一个是什么呢
叫max por
它的核心目的是什么呢
他就专门去找那个就是当前这个主分支的
这个agent的缺点
这个听上去有点抽象
比较复杂
但实际上你可以理解成
就是说因为真实的我在训练游戏AI的时候
我其实可以训练出很多种不同的版本的
那么AI这个人工神经网络它有个特点是什么呢
你越确定它它就越强
但是呢他的某种能力越强的时候
他的能力就会越来越不通用
他就会越来越专门化
大家去想象一下生物进化中是不是有这个特点
其实你去理解这个东西
你可以理解生物进化
就是说他如果在一个岛上
永远只跟自己去竞争啊
他会有些特征就会呃变得非常非常的强
但其他方面的特征就会变得非常的弱
你看似他很强大
但实际上任何一个外来物种
什么叫外来物种
比如说呃假设有其他的人类玩家
人类因为人类玩家的风格多种多样嘛
那这个AI的话
如果正对位
他打起来很厉害
对不对
但是如果风格一旦不对的话
他马上就输呗
失那个失败的其实就跟进化一样的
就是说那就这个生物也是一样
它进化的很强很强
比如说它的飞行能力非常强对吧
它所以跟自己的竞争中
他永远是有优势的
但是他一旦碰到了一个诶
不按常理出牌的这个外来物种的话
他可能当场就没有
所以我们在以warning
就进化这个像阿尔法star这样的AI的时候
我会给他做三个完全不同的分身
而且每个分身都有完整的链路
第一个是主分身
就是这是我最终输出的
他会和所有的人类去打
那么还有一类呢是专门去跟所有的其他的这些
分身去打的人
就是立刻立刻的意思
你可以联盟的这样的一个竞争对手
他这个东西相对能力会综合一点
那么还有一个呢就叫做叫may exposure
就是他专门去找当前的这个主分身的弱点呢
他专门针对的去打
这什么意思呢
就是说呃有哎这个确实有点抽象
但是大家去理解一下啊
比如说我们去训练我们的军队
那我们就会设计什么呢
叫红军和蓝军
大家都听说过红军和蓝军的故事
对不对
那这里面你们知道
我们中国有一支中一个重要的兵种
就是蓝军部队
他专门去找我们我军战法中的所有的弱点
所以我们的红军呢自己跟自己会对抗对吧
但同时的话呢我们也会跟蓝军对抗
但大家注意你这边有个细节
就是说如果红军只和红军对抗
大家知道是有问题的
近亲繁殖对不对
但是呢如果红军只和蓝军对抗
有没有有没有问题呢
其实也有问题
为什么呢
他们彼此就会针对性地做优化
那这样假设我碰到的敌人
他是用红军自己的打法打你的
你很可能会打失败
所以你为了让自己足够强的话
你要故意造出几种不同类型的这个对手
天天去找找你的麻烦
所以这个架构其实很巧妙
真的很巧妙
就是我们这个看每每看到这一段
我就觉得r for a star的这帮人真的是不容易
就是因为你又不可能找到那么多的高水平的
人类玩家去吹你
你的AI这个东西又不像围棋对吧
他的这个解空间
那么确定
他深深造出了三种不同的style的这样的一个选手
然后每天双手互搏
我们叫做左脚踩右脚
最后好不容易把这个阿尔法star的AI
打到了人类这个相对高的这个水平
所以当我们用deep in的方法
去做这个游戏的AI的话
其实这一点真的是非常的重要
这个这个架构的话
大家有机会可以慢慢的理解
就是其实读这个文字能够读得更清楚一点
好可好
那么其实呢就是在做游戏A的时候
我们真正这里面做个summarize
就是说其实核心的选择就是
你到底是选择用这个增强学习还是用监督学习
其实对于有大量的玩家数据的情况下
我们会建议首先用那个监督学习
因为它会让你的training快速的收敛
而且呢如果你的数据量足够大
而且数据质量足够好的话
其实你可以达到一个人类相对不错的水平
这里面取一个阿尔法
阿尔法star这个概念的话
就是他早期的用监督学习的话
已经达到人类相对高的一个
就是比如说业余选手的水平
但是后来再加上一个增强学习的时候
诶
他可以在网上去突破
达到半职业玩家的水平对吧
那么reverse learning的话
它的好处就是说诶他真的这个上限足够的高
真的能产生很多让你觉得非常惊艳的
一些用户的行为
但是它的缺点是什么呢
就训练非常复杂
而且成本真的非常的高
那么什么时候选择reinforcement learning
什么时候选择这个就是suprised learning呢
其实我们自己有一个不成熟的一个认知
就是我们认为就是说如果这个游戏里面
你的奖励是足够密集的
就是说你每做一步
你就知道它的奖励是什么
比如说刚才我们讲的
像那个啊
像这个就是以TRA上的游戏为例
就是你每一步你的球拍的运动没几下
你就能知道能不能打中一个目标的话
那这样你用增强学习
其实是很容易训练出一个好的AI
但是如果像这种比较复杂的什么探索解谜啊
但是你一个动作和你最终的结果之间的关联
非常的不直接
就是他的奖励非常sparse的话
其实这个时候那个reinforcement learning
其实效果是比较难的
除非像那个阿凡达那样
你就真的花了很多功夫
才能达到一个比较好的结果
如果是一个小游戏的话
你这样做实际上是很划不来
那么实际上的话呢
这个时候我们会认为supervised learning
可能是个更好的一个结果
那么所以的话呢
这个是我觉得我们觉得就是说啊
这两个方法你一定要综合的来看
综合的去选择
那么其实这一点的话
这也是我们今天讲的这个machinery最后一节课
这节课这个PPT呢
实际上是我们这个在看那个帝国时代四
在tb c上的一个talk
我觉得他这个就是作者总结的非常的好
他就说啊
其实当我们真的把这么好的一个
就是深度学习的技术用在游戏里面的话
大家千万要注意
这时候一定要考虑费效比
他举了个例子
就是说DeepMind为了做这个alpha star
花了2.5个亿美金对吧
但是这里面肯定
我觉得不不应该是纯机器的费用
可能还有些人工费用
但是呢他说他每一次对这个策略进行探索
他还额外的花1300万美金
我的天呐
这就是全是钱
其实现在大家讲的深度学习的时候
我们有个玩笑
就是说深度学习真的是个算法竞争吗
好像目前看好像没有那么可怕
其实真正重要的竞争是什么呢
第一个是你的这个啊
应该来讲你的数据对吧
你有没有足够大的数据
第二件事情是什么呢
哎就是你的算力
就是你的钱
比如说像著名的gp three对吧
这个训练一次好像是几千万美金
所以很多那个AIG的同人就去诟病
他说你这个算法没有什么了不起
就是你算力足够大对吧
所以其实当时我们在做这个游戏的
你们AI的时候
我们确实需要考虑这个成本
所以当时呢就是在这个就是呃
就是那个微软的同学们
他在做那个帝国时代的时候
他就总结
就是说实际上你们在不同的架构里面
其实可以考虑把几种算法混合用
就是说比如说你用这种深度神经网络的时候
你可以在微观层面
你外面套的是behavior tree f那个有限状态机
这种方法里面的话呢
我用一些一些小量的角色
我用这种neural network
让他有一些更human like跟人人性化
但他训练也好
它的整个这个就是演这个就是说演义也好
其实成本非常的低诶在宏观层面的话
诶我首先用那个neural network做宏观的战略决策
为什么呢
因为他这样会让这个行为看上去
更加的具有这种策略感对吧
其实如果你用这个
你把整个局面转化成各种各样的map
你用神经网络说决定
比如说我是要战争还是和平
这种角色很多时候还很真的很像人
但是你真的决定了战争之后
你做了什么动作
比如说我决定出兵
决定造多少兵的时候
其实策划用BEHABREE
用有限状态机做起来可能会比AI做的更好
但如果你真的有无限的实力的话
你AI做也可以
所以的话呢这一点实际上也是
这个就是当我们真的在游戏通用AI策略的时候
要综合的考虑
所以我一直这样讲
就说这节课中
就这两节课中讲的几乎所有的算法
其实在我们真实的一个游戏里面
可能都是有用的
就无所谓高下之分吧
都是看你要用在正确的场合
那这就是我们这节课的内容
那这节课呢啊真的很硬核
我发现时间已经快三个小时了
那这节课硬核的一个另外一个例证是什么呢
就是我们终于创造了史无前例的reference
这个案例就是参考文献
我们列了整整的七大页啊
大家可以欣赏一下
这几天是讲这个HTN的对吧
那这几篇呢是讲GP的
大家可以看一下
然后啊这几篇是讲MCTS的对吧
就是蒙特卡罗TRSEARCHING好
这集也是讲什么呢
讲machine learning的
你看我们基本上把最近的GDC上的machine learning的文章
全部给扫了一遍
这个确实这节课的肝度绝对是感人的对吧
包括就是machine learning在game行业里面的一些应用
我们都扫了一遍
确实为了准备这节课的话
我们的小伙伴我们有个小同学
有个同学跟我说
他已经连续21天没有休息了
只写了我们游戏里面这里面的一个章节啊
所以希望这个这节课的内容的话
能够对大家的就是学习也好
对游戏引擎的掌握好有帮助
好的
那我们今天的课程的话基本上到此了呢
同学们有没有什么问题
我们留几分钟
留几分钟的时间
大家有问题的话
我们可以尝试回答一下哇
这个问题问的太尖锐了
有同学问我说AI除了在游戏里应用
还能用在哪个地方
这个问题实际上是AI能用在很多地方
顺便手benefit了我们的游戏
因为AI实际上是真的
今天生活的很多机会
所有的方面吧
比如说你上网搜搜索呀
你打开你的淘宝都是AI的支撑吧
那么就是说游戏的话
实际上是啊
但是游戏和AI的关系其实非常的
明明就是非常的密切
为什么呢
因为AI是需要它首先需要training的
而在现实世界中的training的话
它成本很高
而且他很多输出输出是不明确的
但是游戏是一个模模拟事件嘛
所以的话其实未来的话
我一直认为就是有用游戏引擎的技术
其实我们可以做什么呢
做对整个世界的模拟simulation
那么我们有了这样的一个simulation之后的话呢
其实我们可以train出更好的AI
比如说像我们的无人驾驶对吧
它的training很现在有一个很重要的一部分
就是在我们的游戏引擎里面进行training
所以这就是一个相互就是帮助的这样一个过程
包括我我想象一下未来的家居机器人对吧
一个复杂的家庭环境的模拟
包括这里面有很多人人类行为的模拟
那这些东西我们可以交个游戏引擎来做
那这里面训练出的AI的话也会更加的聪明
它反向的也会让这个游戏看上去更真实对
所以说我觉得就是这两个关系
还是非常的密切哇
这个问题问的很专业了
就是AI游戏中的AI到底是在CPU上跑
还是在GPU上跑
那其实在现在的游戏引擎AI
因为就是那个演艺这件事情
并不是特别的计算量很高
因为在游戏的真实游戏中
我不会在现场游戏中去training这个AI
所以呢很多时候我们都是用一些
就是现成的框架
那么其实现在的游戏AI呢
在CPU上跑问题也不是很大
就是利用ca芯片啊
利用将来的一些
就是说像手机上还有很多tensor CORE啊对吧
这些在CPU上直接就是在CPU或GPU上
甚至是AI的芯片是直接加速这件事情啊
他应该就是个工程的问题
就是完全是取决于我们的工程选择啊
第三问题还有有没有学习玩家输入的先例啊
这个我猜可能是有吧
就是我自己现在已经问我
我一时想不起来
因为学习玩家行为就是其实是很常见的
就是我们经常会把玩家的这个操作学下来
就是这个指挥啊
动作啊决定成本
但是玩家的输出
比如说这个上上下下左左右右
这个东西有没有学习的先例
我猜大概率有举个例子啊
比如说我要去做一个
比如像拳皇这样的游戏的这个AI的话
我有可能就直接学玩家的手柄输入了
这样的话我学出来AI看上去应该更聪明
更有意思
所以的话呢我认为这件事情应该是大概率有的
但只是我们可能没有找到这些相关的资料
好的
那我们今天创造了新纪录
整整三个小时对吧
我们终于又卷出了新的高度
那我们接下来的话呢
就是在下一周我们可以好好的休息一下了
我要我要偷个懒嘛对吧
我下周我要好好休息一下
然后我们争取在下下周我们在新的章节再见好
谢谢同学们